MALE SPEAKER: All right.
So don't be shy.
Have some questions over there.
Otherwise, straight
to the raffle.
There's got to be
some questions.
OK, there's an audience mic
over in the middle right here.
Right there.
Yeah, just go.
Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: You
need to speak--
MALE SPEAKER: Walk up to the mic
and ask your Android question.
AUDIENCE: I have to
speak into the mic.
JAKE: Like a pirate, loudly.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Jake.
Promises in ServiceWorker, why
the Promise API in particular?
JAKE: Well, every API
from now on in the DOM
is, if it's async
success/failure, it's Promises.
That's it.
Callbacks are dead
for this stuff.
Events are only valid
if it's an event,
if you get multiple of them.
So in some ways, things
like image loads,
yeah, that can happen
many times on one object.
Everything is Promises now.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: And a
ServiceWorker question.
So you said about the
traditional web cache
that the problem there
is that it competes
with all the stuff on
the web, basically.
And that's why
it's not effective.
But why is that not going to
happen to the ServiceWorker
cache once everybody
starts using it?
JAKE: At the moment, stuff
the ServiceWorker cache
is only gone when you remove it.
Like, it's reliable.
There might be a
permissioning step
once you use a certain amount,
like over your free quota.
But we want it to kind of be
the user's responsibility,
especially after they've
given permission,
to remove that stuff.
Like if you go to a
website and it still
has some stuff in
the cache, and that
makes you run out of space, we
don't want it to go and delete
Netflix, the Netflix
site, and all the movies
that you've cached
for your flight.
So it's going to be like
the same as native apps.
We will promote
this stuff in here's
the sites that are using
the most disk space.
Which ones do you
want to remove?
AUDIENCE: And one more thing.
It seems very easy to register
to listen to push messages.
But how do I actually push
a message to your phone?
JAKE: Yeah, so you'll get an
ID and a URL in that object.
And that URL will be the
way you send the messages
to your server.
And that communication is going
to be standardized as well.
So even if you get an
Apple one or a Firefox one,
the way you send the messages,
it will be standardized.
You will have to have
registered with that service,
in the same way that you
do on Android and things.
Thank you.
It doesn't work with pale skin.
But yeah, so the same message,
but different endpoints.
MALE SPEAKER: Does anybody
else have a question for Jake?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
actually not to Jake.
What's the biggest
thing standing
in the way for Android
performance and browser
performance with
garbage collection?
Which browser--
MALE SPEAKER: I heard Android, I
heard browser, I heard garbage.
AUDIENCE: Garbage collection.
MALE SPEAKER: Hey, now.
AUDIENCE: Memory?
Memory?
MALE SPEAKER: I'm just
reporting what I heard.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: What
is the question?
AUDIENCE: What's the
biggest things standing
in the way of better
performance on Android
and also mobile web
browser and Android?
What are those things?
Is it the VM doesn't
manage SSD memory fast?
Is it garbage collection?
Is it caching?
What's the biggest
things that you can't fix
or you're really stymied?
MALE SPEAKER:
Nothing's can't, right?
It's all just software.
So I would say the
biggest advance
that we've had recently
is ART, which is now
default, particularly
the L preview.
ART is not only default,
actually, it's the only.
So welcome to ART, which
improves garbage collection
greatly.
Actually, we talked
about it so much
in depth on the
Android developers
backstage podcast that we
went on to two episodes,
because we just kept
talking and talking.
So there's a lot of details
about why and how that works
and how that improves
garbage collection.
There were a lot of
things about Dalvik
that were hampering performance
for garbage collection, just
how it was written
from the beginning
that we had a hard
time working with.
ART allowed us to
get beyond those
and allows garbage collection
to work much better
in general, parallel
garbage collection,
being able to move very
large objects like bitmaps
off the regular heap so
that everything else that's
very small can be collected
much more quickly.
There's a lot of
optimizations that we've
been able to make
with ART, and I
think there's a lot more ground
to be covered there as well.
AUDIENCE: Is it
optomized for SSDs?
MALE SPEAKER: I can't
answer that question.
AUDIENCE: I'll look it up.
Don't worry about it.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
OK.
JAKE: On the mobile web, we're
suffering from Paint, I'd say.
But we're working
on that as well.
MALE SPEAKER: Cool.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Sorry, I'm showing
up a bit late,
so I don't know if this
question's been asked already.
MALE SPEAKER: Should we go
over the presentations again?
There were just four of us.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: It'll take like
two hours, and we'll be done.
MALE SPEAKER: As
long as there's beer.
AUDIENCE: Argh.
Argh.
AUDIENCE:So I heard a talk a few
days ago about how Instagram,
they have part of their
app was using WebView.
And they switched from
WebView back to native.
MALE SPEAKER: Yay.
AUDIENCE: And I was
wondering-- oh, sorry.
Maybe I shouldn't ask this.
But I was wondering how
can we, as developers,
plan for WebView
evolving as well?
Because we can't always depend
on Chrome features or Firefox.
MALE SPEAKER: So we do
have Chrome WebView.
So that's the answer.
AUDIENCE: Ah, I see.
But then we have to depend
on Chrome being installed.
MALE SPEAKER: No.
No.
So Chrome WebView
is a separate thing.
It's basically a replacement
for the old WebView.
And you get all the benefits
of Chrome, the platform.
We're working on the
self-update story, as well.
So that's been a big pain
point for a lot of people
to use in WebView.
So you're going to get
new features faster.
And we're still
working out the details
of how that upgrade
cycle's going to happen.
but it's there.
You can use it today.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
So it's decoupled from the OS?
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
AUDIENCE: Ah.
Oh, sorry.
Thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: Yep.
Yep.
That was the big change.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I've got a question
about ServiceWorkers.
Yes, ServiceWorkers.
Woo!
So I was wondering,
is there any work
being done to create a
polyfill for ServiceWorkers
on unsupported browsers?
Or would that even be possible?
Like would it be possible
to build ServiceWorkers
on top of AppCache?
JAKE: Because of the
way the ordering of it
is that it's more the other way
around, so that you can build
AppCache on top
of ServiceWorker,
because it's the lower level
thing with more freedom.
We did actually
build a polyfill,
but it was a node server
that acted as a proxy.
And all the ServiceWorker stuff
ran in the node environment.
And that wasn't for you can
use in production sites,
it was just a means for
us to test some stuff.
Yeah, the polyfills
are really going
to live in terms of things
like the cache API, which
are hopefully going
to go away soon.
It would be interesting to
see if the Chrome for iOS
could patch some of this in
with their network stack.
That would be exciting.
But it's not something
we've looked into yet.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Just got a
question similar to what
somebody else was asking.
Just more to encourage
discussion amongst you guys
and see what you
guy's thoughts are
on the hybrid or mobile
web versus native.
And if we have all these
APIs, the HTML5 is opening up
all these native functionality,
push notification,
batteries, so forth,
it's bringing closer
to the native application
development environment.
What will the future be?
More HTML5?
Or a mixture?
Because Facebook's app,
I think, some portions
still run on WebView.
Most of it is native.
So what is the
future looking like?
MALE SPEAKER: I lost the
thread somewhere about halfway
through.
Were you looking for a
rumble, or a group hug?
AUDIENCE: Both.
MALE SPEAKER: So, I mean--
MALE SPEAKER: Here, I'll do it.
MALE SPEAKER: Like-- what-- OK.
MALE SPEAKER: Do you--?
OK.
So the politically
correct answer
here is that we are
in an increasingly
device-heavy and mobile world.
And as users want to experience
your content on these devices,
they expect them to have some
of the similar capabilities that
are presented on the
devices themselves.
So if you expect
that your platform is
going to continue to be
relevant on these devices,
you would expect that more of
the device-specific interfaces
are going to be
exposed over time.
This is sort of the
conundrum that most of us
sit in here, as someone
trying to bridge
both worlds in this
kind of argument.
As a developer, you
have to ask yourself
where you're investing
your source code,
because that's the big thing.
Do you write
everything in HTML5?
Do you write it in Java?
Do you write it in C++?
Which you should be
writing everything in C++,
because I expect it.
MALE SPEAKER: Only games.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
But the truth is that, in an
increasingly mobile world,
you should expect
that the web should
want to adapt to
that environment,
because that's what users
are immersed in right now.
And for things to stay relevant
and things to move forward,
you have to expose
APIs in such a way
that users can get
attachment to that.
That keeps Chet from
saying bad things.
And I hope that keeps Jake
from saying bad things as well.
MALE SPEAKER: Let me try
some positive things as well.
So I think both platforms are
advancing on various fronts.
We're making performance better,
both on the web and native.
And that's good.
And if you just take
a longer term view,
I think there shouldn't
be that difference.
You should be able to
build a really fast, nice,
and fluid web app
and a native app.
That shouldn't be
the difference.
And the users don't care
if the experience is good.
Then it really
becomes a question
about what is the thing
that I'm trying to deliver?
So for example, the
web really excels
at these ephemeral
experiences where
I don't need to commit
to installing a thing,
and going through a complicated
opt-in process and check boxes.
I just want to check
if the ticket's
available for this
freaking concert.
Right?
I don't need an app for that.
That's a perfect use case
for something like the web.
Should that feel like an app?
That shouldn't
make a difference.
Right?
So the context is
what matters there.
And I think we'll
find that that's
where we're going to
be headed increasingly.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
So I'll just add one
final point which
is, again, the context matters.
It depends on what your
application is trying to do.
If it's a migration
story from the web,
that's a great place to start.
If it's a really simple
application, or the UI
that you are going for ties
in really closely with the way
you want to look on the web,
that's a great reason, too.
If it's a really
complicated app,
and you want the
greatest performance,
and you want it to look
like the rest of the things
on the native device,
that's the point
at which you start considering
native as the real way to go.
Because these are still
constrained devices, right?
You have limited battery.
You have limited power.
You have limited performance.
And you need to do the right
thing for your application,
so that it works well for
the user in that situation,
not so that it works well for
the developer that didn't want
to spend as much time
developing the application that
worked well.
It worked OK everywhere.
So do the thing that works
well for the platforms
that you're trying to target.
JAKE: But in terms of the
developer spending time,
it's going to take you a lot
more time to do an iOS app
and an Android app
than it's going
to do to build one
thing on the web.
And then you've got
desktop as well.
MALE SPEAKER: Actually,
if you use C++,
you can get it on
both platforms.
[LAUGHTER]
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: You can look
awful everywhere with C++.
MALE SPEAKER: Is that what--
MALE SPEAKER: I think that's
what he was trying to say.
No, absolutely.
That's exactly the
point is that I
think the web is a solution for
everywhere is sort of the thing
that you would think of first
and say, well, if I write it
in this, then it's basically
the same code everywhere.
But is it the right
experience everywhere?
Right?
And for some
applications, absolutely.
For other applications,
there's more going on,
or there's reasons that you want
to target native capabilities,
or whatever.
And then that's the point at
which you want to say, well,
is that the right solution?
Or is there a mix of solutions
that we have a Chrome view
and we have some
native components?
Or we have all native
components, or all WebView?
Whatever.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
What the web needs to
do is to get to a point
where the difference in
performance doesn't matter.
Because this is
why we see things
like Encarta not
happening anymore.
You know, we see
things like Cinemania
not happening anymore.
And having a native email
client, a lot of people
don't anymore, because
although native can always
beat the web in
terms of performance,
that performance difference
doesn't matter as much.
So mobile, this is
why we see-- well,
like I was saying
in my talk-- this
is why we see much
native ruling on mobile,
because that difference is
too great at the moment.
But we're fixing it.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: Also, C++.
I just wanted to get that in.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Are there any other
questions for Jake?
Quick, quick, quick.
AUDIENCE: I have no
questions for Jake.
I have a question for Ilya.
Actually, two questions.
From your accent, I detect
that you're probably
not from around these parts.
Where are you from originally?
AUDIENCE: Chico.
AUDIENCE: Chico?
MALE SPEAKER: That's it.
That's what I'm going with.
AUDIENCE: No, really.
I was going to ask you.
I think we all
anticipated you would
speak like a pirate in the
Argot of your country of origin.
Is that possible?
AUDIENCE: He said Chico.
AUDIENCE: Are you from the US?
MALE SPEAKER: No.
Chico.
AUDIENCE: It's Chico.
AUDIENCE: You're from Chico,
which is not in the US?
MALE SPEAKER: No.
I think I need a drink now.
AUDIENCE: I've already
had enough drinks.
It's OK.
No pirates?
MALE SPEAKER: No, no pirates.
AUDIENCE: Come on.
AUDIENCE: Call his bluff.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: Next.
AUDIENCE: Har, C++ question.
AUDIENCE: Yar.
AUDIENCE: When Chromium
will migrate to C++ 11?
AUDIENCE: C++.
Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: You mean
at the source code level,
like Chromium?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
MALE SPEAKER: Does
that matter to you?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Is that like a big thing to how
you're-- so I'm guessing from
that question that you're
writing some sort of plug-ins
or interfaces, or working with
Chrome as a fork to roll it
out.
MALE SPEAKER: Is it
a religious thing?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm
trying to figure out.
If you're writing
web apps, you don't
care what's running
under the hood.
If you're writing
mobile apps, maybe.
But if you're writing plug-ins,
you should be using NaCl.
AUDIENCE: It's just a
question of good taste.
I know C++ 11 makes C++
code more, say, readable.
MALE SPEAKER: So I'm going to
say that a lot of programmers
have a lot of opinions.
JAKE: No, they do not.
MALE SPEAKER: And I think,
if you can look at the crew
up here and realize that a
lot of opinions are personal,
and then a lot of
opinions are political,
and a lot of opinions
are handed down.
MALE SPEAKER: Wrong.
Wrong.
MALE SPEAKER: Shut up.
Stow your noise.
So trying to hypothesize
on whether or not
a very successful
piece of software
is going to migrate to
a minor change-- or even
a major change-- in a
language for the sake
simply of changing to it
is a lot of readability,
and a lot of rework, and a lot
of people, and a lot of time,
and a lot of open source systems
that have to move around.
Is it impossible?
No.
But there's a lot of decisions,
and a lot of preferences,
and a lot of politics,
and a lot of people
between where we are today and
where that decision might lie.
AUDIENCE: So the answer
is you don't know.
MALE SPEAKER: Yar.
[LAUGHTER]
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: So a
good place to ask
that same question
would be Blink Dev.
So if you just go to
the group-- honestly,
I'd encourage you to
just go there and ask
that same question.
AUDIENCE: Just [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Well, so that is the
right group of people.
Certainly, one of
the big motivations
behind starting Blink, as
a project to begin with,
was to be able to
decouple and fix
a lot of things, do clean
up, and all the rest.
There's ongoing projects.
Just today, I was
reading a new proposal
for doing a ton of clean
up in a render stack.
So there's
initiatives like that.
Does that mean that
your particular flavor
will be fixed tomorrow?
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
MALE SPEAKER: WebKit
has migrated already.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: Good.
MALE SPEAKER: Never heard of it.
MALE SPEAKER: Never heard of it?
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: Do they
have ServiceWorker?
MALE SPEAKER: No.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Well, thanks for
all the questions.
We want to have a big round of
applause for all four speakers.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Just going to take a
couple of pictures,
and then we're going
to go on to the raffle.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: Oh,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: So I want to make
sure that we thank everyone
properly, by the way,
for-- this one's mine.
Fantastic.
Guess what I'm doing tonight?
So I want to make sure that
we thank the speakers properly
and thank all of you here
for being here tonight.
So I think we should
go for one more
round of our "Perf
Matters to Me" song.
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: Yar.
[CHEERS]
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Do you
think we can do that?
MALE SPEAKER: Let's do it.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Come on, speakers.
You skipped out on the last one.
Get up here this time.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: AV crew?
Can we get some of
the AV crew here?
MALE SPEAKER: Singing
while drinking.
MALE SPEAKER: Singing this
again is not a good way to--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: All hands on deck.
MALE SPEAKER: Now,
everyone here is
going to sing too again, right?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, come on.
It's not too late.
You start drinking
at noon, midnight.
Yar?
AUDIENCE: Yar.
MALE SPEAKER: Yar?
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Here we go, you lily
livered bilge rats.
I want to hear you all the
way back at the mainland.
MALE SPEAKER:
(SINGING) Yo, ho, ho.
Perf matters to me.
Yo, ho, ho.
We profile, we think,
we fix, and we test.
Perf matters,
me-hearties, yo ho.
We never give up,
we never will rest.
Drink up, me hearties, yo, ho.
Yo, ho, ho.
Perf matters to me.
(YELLING) [INAUDIBLE]
land lubbers!
(SINGING) Be ye mobile or
web, we only want booze.
Drink up, me hearties, yo, ho.
We're really bad eggs,
and strange is our brew.
Drink up, me hearties, yo, ho.
Yo, ho, ho.
Perf matters to me.
When yer app be slow,
[INAUDIBLE], drink up,
me hearties, yo, ho.
When users be leaving and
never be glad, drink up,
me hearties, yo, ho.
Profile your app,
and fix it up right.
Perf matters, me
hearties, yo, ho.
Never a slow app,
without a good fight.
Perf matters, me
hearties, yo, ho.
Yo, ho, ho.
Perf matters to me.
Drink up, me hearties.
Perf up, me hearties.
Perf matters to me.
Thank you, everyone,
for tonight.
It's been a fantastic
event on the live stream.
Thank you, everyone.
This is a fantastic
Perf Like a Pirate Day.
We'll see you next year.
[APPLAUSE]
[CHEERS]